you know if you read the modern history
textbooks
reagan is almost invariably portrayed as
this right-wing ideologue
who held fast to positions that were no
longer true
but he was just basically an old fogey
and he wasn't
in tune with the step of modern times
but that was not true at all reagan
didn't just see
policies or plans of government in terms
of
left and right he saw them in human
terms
so reagan was actually there at the
beginning
there at the beginning of the breakdown
of civil society and the creation of the
welfare state
his father living in dixon was actually
responsible for administering a number
of these new deal programs
and when the men first showed up to be
on relief
men who had worked their whole lives
long who had supported their families
who
who truly loved their work they were
they were down they were beaten down
they couldn't
stand up as straight they didn't feel as
good about themselves in taking handouts
and so what reagan's father did very
adeptly was actually find little odd
jobs around the county that they could
do
so they could feel like that they were
working for this relief this
much-needed relief they needed that they
had to have for their families
well at any rate at one point they
stopped coming in
for these jobs and
reagan's father didn't know why until he
asked him and they said well
because we're essentially now on another
program
which was just straight out welfare it
had nothing to do with works progress
had nothing to do with odd jobs to make
feel like you were earning your keep
and what seems to have happened is it
was just too tempting
and there was another bureaucracy in
town and that bureaucracy didn't want
them to work
it wanted them to be on the dole because
that's where
their interest was the bureaucrats
interest
in having that other program and reagan
reflecting years later on this
because it took him a while for the
stall to sink in realize
that government bureaucracies are there
to protect themselves
they're not there with the best interest
of the men and women that they claim to
serve
they're there to remain to maintain a
permanent establishment
that then eventually reigns over the
souls of man
and reorders those souls so that you
come to think of yourself
not as an autonomous human being not as
a self-governing
adult but as a dependent
and that's the business that reagan
didn't want to have anything to do with